.
Scheisse.
Oh, oh.
Ich muss nach Hause.
- Warum?
Scheisse. Kannst du mir helfen?
- Sicher, stell es auf den Boden.
Was ist passiert?
- (Frau) Steck sie aus.
Eine klebrige Sauerei.
Der Boden ist eh schmutzig.
Das Mischen der Haselnusscreme
endet in einem zünftigen Schlamassel.
Den amerikanischen Traum leben.
Marina und Mike wollen in Florida
ein Waffelrestaurant eröffnen.
Das ist das Heiligtum,
das Herzstück unseres Ladens.
Von diesen haben wir drei Stück.
Aber keine heissen Waffeln
ohne Fähigkeitszeugnis.
Ja, wir müssen bestehen.
Wir haben etwas Druck.
400 Tiere und 240 ha Land
an der Atlantikküste.
Tschüss.
Für diesen Bauernbetrieb
verlässt Familie Wieser die Heimat.
Die erwachsenen Kinder
bleiben in der Schweiz.
Ihre kleine Herde
nehmen sie mit.
Geschafft. Ich bin geschafft,
die Tiere sind geschafft,
und wir haben es geschafft.
In Frankreich
erhoffen sich die Bauern
mehr unternehmerische Freiheit.
Ici on peut commencer.
Späte Liebe.
Eva Dudle und Philippe Sguaitamatti
wollen in der Toskana
ein Agriturismo betreiben.
Die italienische Variante
für Ferien auf dem Bauernhof.
800 Olivenbäume pflanzen sie an,
doch an einer Stelle
scheint der Boden unfruchtbar.
Non vorrei
che ti creassero dei problemi.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Florida-Auswanderin Marina Marrer
ist erleichtert:
Sie hat eine bedeutende Hürde
geschafft.
Das ist Schweiss, purer Schweiss.
Ich habe Blut geschwitzt.
Man muss den Foodmanager haben.
Ich habe wirklich gezittert,
ob ich bestehe oder nicht.
Jetzt hat es geklappt.
Das ist wichtig.
Ohne das dürfen wir nicht eröffnen.
Hi, good morning.
Have a good day.
- (Beide) Same to you.
Monatelang haben Mike und Marina
diesen Tag herbeigesehnt.
Den Tag, an dem der Umbau
ihres Waffelrestaurants
endlich abgeschlossen sein wird.
So cool,
momentan bekommen wir immer Pakete
und wissen gar nicht, warum.
Seit sechs Monaten Weihnachten.
Pünktlich eingetroffen: die
letzte Dekoration fürs Restaurant.
Ah.
Pflanzen.
- Pflanzen, super.
Vorschriftsgemäss aus Plastik.
Du kannst diese zwei Blätter
noch dranmachen - drei sogar.
Die musst du ineinanderstecken.
- Die stinken.
Nein, die riecht echt.
Das riecht wie Erde.
So schön.
Wegen der Pandemie kam der Umbau
ihres Waffelshops kaum voran.
Die Jungunternehmer
verloren viel Zeit und Geld.
Doch diese frustrierenden Monate
sind endlich Geschichte.
Morgen findet
das sog. Soft Opening statt,
die Generalprobe
zur richtigen Eröffnung.
Haben wir alles?
- Ich glaube ja.
Eingeladen sind Influencer,
Presseleute, Bekannte und Nachbarn.
Hey!
- Hey. Just one moment.
* Sie buchstabieren auf Englisch. *
L-e ...- B-r-o-n.
Thank you.
- See you, bye bye.
Hey.
- How is it going?
At 5 pm.
Bist du zufrieden?
- Mhm.
Marinas und Mikes American Dream
nimmt endlich wieder Fahrt auf.
* Hackbrettversion
von Göläs "Uf u dervo" *
Unterwegs in der Toskana.
Die Kindergartenlehrerin Eva Dudle
hat Frühlingsferien.
Eva hat gemischte Gefühle, denn etwas
Grundlegendes hat sich geändert:
Eva und Philippe sind kein Paar mehr.
Bereits seit Wochen vor Ort
im Agriturismo
ist Gutsverwalter
Philippe Sguaitamatti.
Er bereitet Evas Ankunft vor.
Das wird das Bett für Eva.
Ob sie genau das wollte, was
rausgekommen ist, weiss ich nicht.
Aber das wird es sein.
Ja, dann halt nicht.
Fertig lustig, liebe Latten.
Jetzt müsst ihr dran glauben.
Die beiden
teilen das Bett nicht mehr.
Die Initiative für die Trennung
ging von Eva aus.
Sie hat mir mehr oder weniger
unmissverständlich klargemacht,
dass sie mit mir ...
keine Beziehung mehr haben will.
Tja, so ist das Leben eben.
Trotzdem wollen sie an ihrem
Auswanderungsprojekt festhalten.
Aus Liebe soll nun eine freundschaft-
liche Geschäftsbeziehung werden.
So. Grüezi.
- Hallo.
Ui, wo hast du denn
deine Kilos gelassen?
Die habe ich irgendwo verteilt,
mit 13'000-15'000 Schritten pro Tag.
Unglaublich,
so ein junger, knackiger Mann.
Da staunst du, was?
Hoi.
- Hoi, Grüezi.
Hoi, du!
Philippe lebt im Hauptgebäude.
Schau, ich habe mich hier
einquartiert mit dem Dings.
Wenn du willst, kannst du auch
hierhin kommen, mir ist es egal.
Das ist nicht das Problem.
Auf der anderen Seite habe ich dir
ein Häuschen vorbereitet.
Wie erwartet:
Eva will ihr eigenes Bett.
Schön!
Wow, du hast schon das Bett bezogen?
So gut.
Schön.
Den habe ich dir
heute Morgen reingestellt,
damit du deine Kleider - oder was
du möchtest - verstauen kannst.
Was brauchst du noch?
Es hat ein Badetuch.- Vielen Dank.
Das ist jetzt
schon zum zweiten Mal gemäht.
Am Montag
bringen sie mir den Traktor.
Jetzt bist du glücklich, nicht wahr?
Darum geht's nicht.
Ich habe keine Chance ...
Du hast immer gesagt,
das sei deine Vision.
Aber ohne den Traktor habe ich
keine Chance, durchzukommen.
Wir haben immer gesagt:
"Auf dem Traktor."
Hat er ein Steuerrad?
- Ja, sicher.
Steuerrad, Sitz, alles.
* Akkordeonversion
von Göläs "Uf u Dervo" *
In Frankreich auf dem Hof Les Aubiers
geht's ums grosse Geld:
400 Tiere, der Futterbestand und
die landwirtschaftlichen Maschinen
wechseln heute ihren Besitzer.
Die Verkäufer, samt Makler,
und die Wiesers
haben sich
im hofeigenen Büro versammelt.
Die Vorbesitzer von Les Aubiers, die
Gebrüder Rondeau und ihre Familien,
hatten den Hof
während Jahrzehnten geführt.
Sandro, der studierte Ökonom,
ist überzeugt:
Hier in Frankreich kann er endlich
gewinnbringend wirtschaften.
Dafür verkauften die Wiesers ihren
18 ha grossen Hof in der Schweiz.
Müssen alle unterschreiben?
Ja, dass die Maschinen
verkauft sind.
Knapp 1 Mio. Euro.
Noch nicht inbegriffen
sind die Gebäude,
das Wohnhaus und das Grundstück.
Schatz, so schnell haben wir noch
nie so viele Traktoren gekauft.
Vous avez payé.
- C'est bon.
Beim Notar werden am Nachmittag
auch Hof und Land überschrieben.
Eine weitere beträchtliche Summe
wird dabei den Besitzer wechseln.
* Hackbrettversion
von Göläs "Uf u Dervo" *
Gutsverwalter Philippe ist zufrieden.
Sein Rasentraktor hält,
was er verspricht.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Trotz Ferien: Eva ist eine Früh-
aufsteherin und immer voller Elan.
Nun bremst der linke Arm
ihren Gestaltungswillen.
Vor einigen Wochen hat sie ihn
im Kindergarten gebrochen.
Mich stresst natürlich, dass ich
jetzt nichts oder wenig machen kann,
weil ich ein einarmiger Bandit bin.
Ich merke,
das tut mir nur mässig gut.
Ich könnte mich
so richtig reingeben,
Zimmer für Zimmer,
putzen und machen und tun.
Soll ich dir das Brot streichen?
- Nein, nein.
Das musste ich gestern auch alleine.
- Was?
Das musste ich gestern im Hotel
auch alleine.- Aha.
Selbst ist die Frau.
- Absolut.
Es war der grosse Coup
zur Pensionierung.
Dann,
wenn's andere gemütlicher nehmen,
wagen Eva und Philippe ein Abenteuer:
ein Agriturismo in der Toskana.
Dafür war Eva bereit,
ein Haus in der Schweiz zu verkaufen.
Was willst du damit,
wie willst du das machen?
Ich würde sagen, wir stellen das
so hin, die zwei Stühle da.
Dann gibt es eine Art Sitzgruppe.
Doch auf die grosse Begeisterung
folgte die Ernüchterung.
Das Projekt schritt voran
und Eva plagten immer mehr Zweifel.
Die gemeinsame Aufgabe liess sie
nicht stärker zusammenwachsen.
Gegensätzlichkeiten, einst anziehend,
irritierten Eva immer mehr.
Wunderbar.
Es wird schon fast wohnlich hier.
Und sie kam zum Schluss, dass sie
beide viel mehr trennt als eint.
Es gab von Anfang an
ganz viele Baustellen.
Bei mir,
ich habe auch meine Geschichte.
Und diese Geschichte ist vielfältig.
Er hat auch
eine vielfältige Geschichte.
Ich bin einfach auch sehr dominant.
Das müssen wir klar sehen,
ich bin keine einfache Frau.
Das habe ich ihm
von Anfang an gesagt.
Ich bin keine Einfache,
sehr dominant.
Ich bin in keiner Art und Weise
auf einen Mann angewiesen.
Im Sinne von jemandem, der mir
ein Loch in die Wand machen muss
mit dem Schlagbohrhammer
oder etwas ausmessen muss.
Das kann ich alles selber.
Von daher
ist es schwierig neben mir.
Ich möchte nicht Mann sein
neben mir.
Ich weiss immer sehr genau,
was ich wie will.
Und wenn nicht, überlege
ich so lange, bis ich es weiss.
Geschäftlich bleibt alles beim Alten.
Eva, die Kapitalgeberin, pendelt
während der Ferien in die Toskana.
Jetzt hat sich wenigstens
der Kauf von diesem Ding gelohnt.
Philippe, der Gutsverwalter,
treibt das Unternehmen voran.
Ich fühle mich nicht abhängig von
ihr. Ich weiss es nicht, aber ...
Nein, es ist ...
Ich sehe nicht, was man
gross ändern will an dem Ganzen.
Es ist, denke ich, ein gutes Konzept
und es hat sich auch bewährt,
dadurch,
dass es viel mehr zu tun gibt,
als wir im Voraus gedacht haben.
Dafür bin ich da, und das kann ich
machen, das ist nicht das Problem.
Ich denke,
das ganze Projekt ist so angelegt,
dass es keine Bedingung sein muss,
dass man ein Paar ist.
Das ist nicht nötig, um
das Projekt realisieren zu können.
Von daher kann man das weiterziehen
und damit weitermachen.
Hoi, du.
* Rockige Version
von Göläs "Uf u Dervo" *
* Die Musik verklingt. *
Monatelang kam Marinas und Mikes
Projekt nur schleppend voran.
Zum Schluss
muss es nun umso schneller gehen.
Warte.
- 1,5 - welcher ist es?
Da.
- Dort.
Zuoberst.
Der oberste, die unteren
gehen nicht. Nur der oberste.
Noch schnell ihr Angebot
auf den Bildschirm hieven:
Waffeln, Glace, Shakes und Drinks.
Mike war einst Schreiner,
dann jahrelang Polizist
und nebenbei Tätowierer.
So war sein Einkommen
Monat für Monat gesichert.
Ich zittere,
ich bin schon sehr nervös.
Nun haben die letzten Monate gezeigt:
Nichts ist sicher
und die Zukunft ungewiss.
Es hat niemand gewusst,
dass dieses komische Virus kommt.
Wir haben
sehr viel mehr Geld investiert
als wir gedacht hatten.
Zusätzlich.
Ein solches Business
habe ich noch nie betrieben.
Das ist fremd für mich.
Servieren ...
Von daher bin schon ...
... etwas nervös.
Die Strominstallation
wird heute einer
abschliessenden Prüfung unterzogen.
Ich gehe etwas an die frische Luft.
Die letzte Hürde vor der Eröffnung.
* Neckische Klänge *
Wenn er noch einmal kommen muss,
kommt er erst am Montag.
Am Freitag
arbeiten die Herren ja nicht.
Das würde bedeuten, unsere Eröffnung
würde ins Wasser fallen.
Was ich schwer nicht hoffe.
Wie ich mich dann erholen könnte,
weiss ich gerade nicht.
* Heitere Rumbaklänge *
Bereits auf Einkaufstour ist Marina,
begleitet von Yves Staub.
Auch Yves ist in die USA ausgewandert
und Partner derselben Gastrokette.
Seit einem Jahr hat er
seinen eigenen Waffelshop in Houston.
Ah, die Getränke.
Willst du die zuerst?
Ja, ich habe sie nur
nach hinten gestellt wegen dem Eis.
Zur Unterstützung der Eröffnung
hätte eigentlich jemand
vom deutschen Hauptgeschäft
in die USA reisen wollen.
Doch Corona
verunmöglichte Flüge in die USA.
Yves aus Houston sprang ein.
Vermutlich hätte ich zu wenig
eingekauft, so vom Bauchgefühl her.
Wenn ich diese Ware anschaue -
das ist abartig.
Nicht liefern lassen -
selber einkaufen. Das ist günstiger.
Ich hasse einkaufen.
Und jetzt hasse ich es noch mehr.
Ich hasse es schon privat.
Jetzt das ... nein.
Ich schicke dann in Zukunft Mike.
Nein, ich mache es nicht gerne.
Zurück zu Mike.
Die Inspektion dauert noch immer an.
Es ist kaum zum Aushalten.
Es macht mich wahnsinnig, zu warten,
bis der - ich kann es nicht anders
sagen - bis der Idiot fertig ist.
Doch alles nur halb so wild -
der Bauleiter gibt das Okay.
Perfect. See you tomorrow.
Urgh.
Wir haben uns zurückgehalten
mit Getränken.
* Sie lacht. *
Einmal mehr geschafft.
* Akkordeonversion
von Göläs "Uf u Dervo" *
Alles unterschrieben
und notariell beglaubigt.
Die Schweizer
können den Hof Les Aubiers
ihr Eigen nennen und einrichten.
Un, deux, trois, allez!
Warte doch, ich muss zuerst
den Plastik wegziehen.
Komm, Mutti.
20 Jahre ist es her,
dass sich die beiden in einer Disco
in Zürichs Agglomeration
kennengelernt haben.
Bald war ihnen klar: Sie wollen
ihr Leben gemeinsam verbringen.
Was machst du? Komm.
Hü, Mutti, komm.
Weisst, du was ich dir gleich gebe?
Also nein, zwei Erwachsene,
die zu doof sind, eine Matratze ...
Ich bin nicht zu doof.
Du hast einfach keine Kraft.
Siehst du? Ein Ruck mit dem Rechten.
Du musst sie noch schieben.
Nein, ich will etwas Distanz zu dir.
Künstlich.
Es hat übrigens
ganz viele Zimmer hier.- Mhm.
Alles war perfekt,
und die beiden heirateten.
Es hat noch eine Schwelle, oder?
- Ja, hier.
Andere Männer tragen die Frauen
über die Schwelle, du den Alkohol.
Doch ihre Liebesgeschichte
hat einen Bruch.
Hä? Aber ich.
Ach, jetzt kommt diese Story.
- Erzähl.
Nein!
Zweimal im Leben denselben Fehler
machen, wie dumm muss man sein?
Du musst alles erlebt haben
im Leben.
Ich fand, ich muss mich
zwischendurch mal scheiden lassen.
Das darf er gerne erzählen,
ich mache den Apéro fertig.
Ich höre zu und greife ein,
wenn du Mist erzählst.
Dann erzähle ich nichts.
Ich schweige wie ein Grab.
Wie das geschah? Ganz normal:
Man trennt sich, lässt sich scheiden
und dann heiratet man wieder.
Dann lernt man sich
nochmals neu kennen.
Nie, nie im Leben hätte ich gedacht,
dass er nochmals kommt.
Definitiv nicht.
Was erzählst du wieder über mich?
Scheisse,
wir haben zu wenig Champagnergläser.
Ich glaube,
drei Stück habe ich gefunden.
Tatsächlich: Die beiden liessen sich
nach sechs Ehejahren scheiden.
Doch gerade mal zwei Jahre später
verliebten sie sich erneut
und heirateten zum zweiten Mal.
Das ist die Sieben.
- Ich spüre es, jawohl.
Jawohl!
- Juhu!
Komm.
- Nicht verzagen, Sandro fragen.
Champagner
ist an diesem Abend ein Muss.
Mit dem Vorbesitzer Patrice
und seiner Freundin Marie-Hélène
wollen sie heute auf
ihr neues Lebenskapitel anstossen.
Bon.
Massa Marittima.
Die Zürcher sind auf Einkaufstour.
Eva weiss, was sie will, und Philippe
weiss, wo sie es finden kann.
Ist jemand drin?
- Hä? Ja.
Lei ... buon giorno.
Vorhangstangen
für die Ferienwohnungen.
Einrichten und kreativ sein,
darauf versteht sich Eva.
Philippe, ganz Gutsverwalter,
bringt die Bescheinigung,
dass sie
eine italienische Firma besitzen.
So können sie
gewisse Ausgaben steuerlich absetzen.
Super.
Ich muss auch eines haben,
um es immer vorweisen zu können.
Allora, grazie mille.
Hast du alles?
- Ja, ich hoffe es.
Deine Kette noch, die haben sie uns
gratis gegeben, erstaunlich.
Es kommt auch nicht jeder
am Montagmorgen dort vorbei
und kauft für mehr als 300 ein.
Man muss ringsherum fahren,
damit man wieder hierhin kommt.
Ich weiss, hinten rum, oben durch.
Ich kenne alles schon wunderbar.
Also, hier kenne ich mich
ziemlich gut aus.
Der Versuch, trotz Trennung
gemeinsam ihren Traum
vom eigenen Agriturismo zu leben,
scheint auf gutem Wege zu sein.
Seleziona.
Caffè Latte.
Okay.
Ich denke, wir bemühen uns jetzt
um eine neue Form des Miteinander.
Ich würde es mal so sagen, ja.
Das ist der Helge,
den ich für 5 Euro gekauft ...
Entschuldigung.
- ... gekauft habe.
Das ist Meer.
Es gibt ja ein Meerzimmer.
Es ist sehr schlicht, aber es
symbolisiert für mich sehr das Meer.
Wenn man das
aus dem hässlichen Ding rausnimmt
und einen schönen,
feinen Rahmen drum macht,
es in unser Meerzimmer hängt mit
vielen anderen Bildern vom Meer,
was mit Meer zu tun hat
und Wellen usw.,
dann wird das ein spannendes
Häuschen, ein Meerhäuschen.
Und welches ist unser Meerhäuschen?
- Das weiss ich noch nicht.
Aha.
Da sind wir noch
in der Findungsphase.
In der Findungsphase, ja.
* Fröhliche, gemütliche Musik *
Tampa in Florida.
Heute um 17 Uhr
ist das Soft Opening,
die Generalprobe der Eröffnung.
Die Schweizer am Cottontail Place
haben kaum geschlafen,
zu nervös sind sie.
Es ist etwas komplett Neues.
Wir arbeiten jetzt
das erste Mal im eigenen Geschäft.
Dann auch der Kundenkontakt.
Ich kann schon Englisch,
aber es macht mich trotzdem nervös.
Wer kommt alles,
kommen viele, kommen wenige?
Kommen überhaupt Leute?
Es sollten schon Leute kommen.
Ja, man weiss es ja nie, darum ...
Um Hündin Djuna
kümmert sich heute die Nachbarin.
Mike hatte
bis spät in die Nacht gearbeitet
und war vor Tagesanbruch
wieder im Laden.
Für Marinas Zertifikat
hat er den geeigneten Platz gefunden.
Auch aus Houston angereist
sind die Waffelprofis Chiara
und ihr jüngerer Bruder Nico.
Sie sind Yves Kinder.
Heute erteilt Yves Marina und Mike
die wichtigste Lektion:
das Teig-Rühren.
Hast du sie gefunden?
- Sure.
Jedem Teigkübel
wird eine vom Franchise-Geber
eigens zusammengestellte
Gewürzmischung beigegeben.
Ein Geheimrezept.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was drin ist.
Wirklich nicht. Nein.
Ich weiss es auch nicht 100%ig.
So ungefähr, aber ...
Aber man muss es auch nicht wissen.
Wichtig ist,
dass es am Schluss schmeckt.
So lange rühren,
bis es keine Klumpen mehr hat.
Du siehst, er wird etwas zähflüssig.
Rühren mit dem Bohrer.
So einfach, wie das ausschaut,
ist es dann doch nicht.
Marina lernt ihre Lektion.
Scheisse.
Oh, oh.
Ich muss nach Hause.
- Warum?
Scheisse. Kannst du mir helfen?
- Sicher, stell es auf den Boden.
(Frau) Steck sie aus.
Scheisse.
- Der Boden ist sowieso schmutzig.
Von oben bis unten
mit Haselnusscreme vollgespritzt.
Zum Glück ist Marina
in einer Viertelstunde zu Hause.
* Akkordeonversion
von Göläs "Uf u Dervo" *
Seit Sandro Besitzer und Chef auf
dem Hof ist, herrschen neue Regeln.
Tagwache ist 1 Std. früher.
Patrice Rondeau
ist nun sein Mitarbeiter.
Statt um 6.30 Uhr
wird neu um 5.30 Uhr gemolken.
Nun als Angestellter
muss der einstige Hofbesitzer Patrice
Sandros Neuerungen mittragen.
Früher melken ist nur eine
der Änderungen auf dem Hof.
* Ruhige Musik *
Ja, sie haben mich
ein bisschen komisch angeschaut.
Aber ...
... es wurde
relativ schnell akzeptiert.
Resp. es gibt keine Diskussionen -
wenn ich das will, will ich das so.
Sie sind sich bewusst,
was für einen Schritt wir machen.
Viele Schweizer würden nicht einmal
aus dem Kanton wegziehen,
geschweige denn aus dem Dorf.
Sie haben schon Respekt.
Wir in der Schweiz
würden jeden Ausländer auslachen,
der so schlecht Deutsch spricht
wie ich Französisch spreche.
Aber ich bekomme alles,
es funktioniert
und sie freuen sich,
dass ich es versuche.
So, Madame, keinen Unfug.
Keinen Unfug.
So, Mama
trinkt noch kurz einen Kaffee.
Auch der kleinste Wieser
hat heute einen grossen Tag:
seinen ersten Schultag in Frankreich.
Gian kam nach Wiesers
zweiten Hochzeit zur Welt.
Hier haben wir die Stifte,
jeder einzelne wird angeschrieben.
Wirklich jeder.
Es wird einfach alles angeschrieben.
Sogar Kleenex muss man mitnehmen.
Und eine Tischunterlage.
Ja.
Und einen Thek hat man hier nicht,
hier hat man Rucksäcke.
So, jetzt
kontrollierst du noch deine Sachen.
Mach es auf, damit du weisst,
wo du deine Sachen hast.
Damit du nachher
nicht lange suchen musst.
Gut? Das sind Stabilo.
Und die für die Tafel hier.
- Bonjour.
Pack das vorne in den Rucksack.
* Perlende Klänge *
Es ist langsam Zeit, dass er
zur Schule geht und etwas lernt.
Eins mal eins gibt eins.
Mhm. Zum Glück
sind Zahlen überall gleich.
Neue Schule, neue Freunde
und alles auf Französisch.
Allo. Schau, Eleni winkt schon.
Okay, es reicht.
Müssen wir uns anmelden?
Weil Gian kaum Französisch spricht,
haben die Eltern ihn vorerst
in einer Privatschule angemeldet.
Sechs Ferienwohnungen
wollen die beiden Zürcher künftig
in ihrem Agriturismo anbieten.
Um als Agriturismo zu gelten,
müssen sie Landwirtschaft betreiben.
Philippe hat dafür
800 Olivenbäume angepflanzt.
Doch an einer Stelle ihres Hains
scheint der Boden unfruchtbar.
Dieser Flecken führte zu Diskussionen
bei der Vertragsunterzeichnung.
Mich erstaunt, dass Roberto
so darauf bestanden hat,
diesen Passus rauszunehmen.
Wegen der Altlasten, oder?
Er kann sich dieser Verantwortung
nicht entziehen.
Ich habe noch einen Stein gefunden,
von dem ich denke,
dass er nach Schutt,
Bauschutt aussieht.
Mit diesem Rot.
Das hier ist eine Sandschicht,
ganz klar.
Aber warum?
- Ich weiss auch nicht.
Unten ist Lehm.
- Darunter kommt gleich Erde.
Hat er gesagt,
wie weit du runtermusst?
Ja, er sagte etwa 20-30, max. 40 cm.
Nimm möglichst von verschiedenen
Sachen, es braucht nicht viel.
Einfach schräg durch
ein paar Brocken nehmen,
damit ich möglichst
von jeder Schicht etwas habe.
Man muss erst runterkommen.
- Es ist komisch hart.
Das ist Lehm.
Die beiden wollen wissen, was mit
dem Boden los ist, und nehmen Proben.
Eva will diese
in der Schweiz untersuchen lassen.
Von blossem Auge ist
nichts Beunruhigendes zu erkennen.
Ich gehe mal da rüber.
Wir nehmen das mal mit.
Wenn er es dann merkwürdig findet,
können wir immer noch
von verschiedenen Orten nehmen.
Das sieht nach Ziegeln aus.
Oder doch nicht.
Ich glaube, ich habe genug. Ich habe
verschiedene Sachen mitgenommen.
American cookies,
cookies and cream.
Hast du alle Stöpsel rausgenommen?
Dieser Deckel muss endlich weg.
10 Min. vor dem Opening
die nächste Panne.
Jetzt reicht's dann,
das ist das zweite Übel heute.
Jetzt reicht's dann.
Damit
kommst du nicht vorwärts, Schatz.
Ich weiss es nicht.
- Bring mir einen Besen.
Wo ist unser Putzzeug?
Merci.
Wenn das über den Boden vorne läuft,
ist er am Arsch.
Sobald es über den Deckel geht,
kommt es gerade nach vorn.
Diese Schachtel schliessen,
auf die andere Stellen,
mit den zwei Deckeln,
dann hinter den Fernseher stellen.
Der erfahrene Yves
bringt Ruhe in die Situation.
Hör auf. Geh dich umziehen,
zur Toilette.- Warum?
Weil es bald losgeht.
Damit wir um 17 Uhr
sicher bereit sind.
Wir machen das hier noch.
Aber 10 Min. reichen nicht mehr,
um mich bereit zu machen.
Ach, komm.
Sich noch einmal so richtig herzen
bevor es losgeht.
Du wirst nervös, nicht?
- Mhm.
Oje. Das kommt schon gut.
Es wird alles gut.
Du bist nicht alleine,
wir sind nicht alleine.
Marie-Hélène hat Aleksandra
unter die Fittiche genommen.
Sie soll den wichtigsten Markt
der Gegend kennenlernen.
Einen solchen Automaten habe ich
noch nie gesehen. Ganz cool.
Der Markt des Städtchens Machecoul.
Sowieso - als Besitzerin von einem
der grössten Höfe der Umgebung
will Aleksandra das Angebot kennen.
Hier findet sie Käse und Joghurt,
die mit Milch von ihrem Hof
produziert worden sind.
Produit corse.
Aleksandra ist froh
um Marie-Hélènes Unterstützung.
Au revoir.
- Au revoir, bonne journée.
Das ist Gold wert.
Sie ist ein herzensguter Mensch,
ich bin wirklich froh.
Ich glaube,
ich wäre etwas überfordert
oder würde meinen Mann traktieren,
dass er mitkommt.
Dass sie mir hilft, ist ein Vorteil
und nicht selbstverständlich.
Zurück nach Saint-Même-le-Tenu.
Schulschluss für Gian.
So. Den kannst du mir geben,
du kannst ihn ausziehen.
So gut! Ich lege ihn kurz
in den Kofferraum, okay?
Ich bin so neugierig.
Bist du müde?
- Mhm.
Dort hinten, beim roten Gitter,
ist der Fussballplatz.
Okay. Da?
- Das rote Gitter.
Da könnt ihr spielen,
und hier esst ihr?
Da essen wir.
- Okay.
Super, mit wem hast du Fussball
gespielt?- Mit meinen Freunden z.B.
Okay. Haben alle
"Guten Morgen, Gian" gesagt?
Zuerst haben alle geschaut.
- Das habe ich gesehen.
Dann haben mich plötzlich
fast alle angesprochen.
Siehst du.- Und ich habe gesagt:
"Non francais".
"Non francais"? Super.
Wenigstens konntest du das sagen.
Oh là là.
Ein gelungener Tag, sowohl für
die Mama, als auch für ihren Gian.
Soll ich die Türen öffnen?
- Ja.
Kurz nach 17 Uhr eröffnet Mike
zum ersten Mal den Waffelshop.
Alle sind parat,
auch ihre vier Studentinnen,
die sie für den Anlass
angestellt haben.
Werden die Nachbarn, die Bekannten,
die Presseleute kommen?
Kommen die Influencer?
So.
Die Influencer,
die auf den sozialen Medien
v.a. die offizielle Eröffnung
promoten sollen.
Hey, welcome. Hi.
Klebt da jeweils
die Hälfte an der Scheibe?
Nein, ich würde es so machen:
Lass die Waffel hier.- Ja.
Geh nach unten mit dem Messer,
dreh hier oben, nimm es dann rüber.
Nico, zuerst Puderzucker und danach?
Zuerst Puderzucker, dann ...
Es ist extrem schwierig,
mit der Sauce zu schreiben.
Das glaube ich.
Es sieht schon geil aus.
Und zum ersten Mal
serviert Mike eine Waffel
als eigenständiger Unternehmer.
Meine erste!
Hi.
Nach all der Aufregung
und den Sorgen: Die Gäste sind da.
Noch wichtiger: Die Waffeln kommen
gut an, auch bei den Influencern.
Enjoy.
Es braucht noch viel Übung.
Doch, doch.
In der nächsten Folge
sind erste Gäste im Agriturismo.
Es regnet kaum, das Wasser ist knapp.
Eine Quelle ist nicht vorhanden,
die andere ist praktisch versiegt.
D.h., wir müssen wieder
nach Wasser suchen.
Die jungen Olivenbäume leiden.
Nun soll Eva weiter
Geld ins Unternehmen schiessen.
Wir müssen einen Brunnen bauen,
damit wir eigenes Wasser haben.
Da ich kein Freund der Banken bin,
ist es für mich immer stressig,
wenn es darum geht,
allenfalls einen Kredit aufzunehmen.
Dann habe ich ein Problem.
In Frankreich
ist die Mähsaison in vollem Gang.
Vater und Sohn spannen zusammen.
Wir sind ein Dreamteam.
Er ist der Traum
und ich bin das Team oder so.
Der Waffelshop fordert
Mike und Marina mehr als gedacht.
Ja, momentan
ist es bei uns etwas ein Stress.
Und im Land
der unbegrenzten Möglichkeiten
lernt Mike das US-Bünzlitum kennen.
Das County schickt wöchentlich
am Dienstag oder Mittwoch
jemanden vorbei, der schaut, ob
alles gut ist, der Rasen gemäht ist.
Ist etwas nicht gut, bekommt man ein
Schreiben, eine penalty von 50 ¤.
# U si stige i Flüger, flüge
mit de Vögu furt, chöme nümme hei.
# U si löh hie aues zrugg,
uf dr Suechi für nes nöis Dahei.
# Si gö hüt nu uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Martina Riedi - 2022